all right
uh hey everyone thank you very much for
stopping in I thought I would take this
opportunity it's been a while since I've
done a live stream but it's also been a
while since I've made a video related to
Japanese pronunciation or pitch accent
so I wanted to take some time today and
do that break down some really useful
Japanese pronunciation and Pitch accent
tips and I try to prepare some graphics
beforehand such that this would be
beneficial more beneficial uh had there
not been Graphics so
um I've got uh everyone's comments down
here on the screen
on my second screen down here so I'll be
trying to answer some questions along
the way but there's going to be a lot of
information in this presentation so I'd
like to just kind of get into it right
now and
um
if if questions really do start piling
in then it will be difficult for me to
choose questions that
um
to choose from questions so if you
really want your question to get
answered then doing like a super chat so
like I don't know like a dollar or
whatever then that'll make it easier for
me to choose so okay let's just get
started so the first thing what I want
to do in this presentation today is I
want to give a
bit of information or a tip for every
sound in the Japanese alphabet
and also break down some really good to
know pitch accident rules so
let's start with the vowels hopefully
you guys can see these vowels up on
screen here
um now normally what I do on my Japanese
pronunciation and Pitch accent series
over on patreon which is linked down in
the bottom right corner I've got a bunch
of Graphics like this that break down
all the sounds in detail and I'll be
using some of these Graphics today but
there was a limit to how much
information I could
uh how many Graphics I could prepare for
this presentation specifically
but um we'll see some graphics like this
throughout the presentation and um
voila so high tech yeah but for the
vowels I won't be doing the vowels for
the individual Graphics instead or I
won't be doing the graphics for the
individual vowels rather I'd like to
just concentrate on
incidentally we'll just go through these
really quick actually so this is the
tongue placement for ah this is
e this is
uh this is
and this is
so that's that's not really entirely
helpful in itself but
I have these Graphics up on screen for
minutes at a time on my on my patreon
series while I break things down so
there are a lot more useful over there
but anyway let's get started what I want
to concentrate on for this particular
row of sounds is the middle vowel
because this is the sound within these
five sounds that I think the most amount
of Learners could benefit from
if they had a little bit of information
and what I mean by this specifically is
that
in English the vowel the u sound
your lips look like this ooh so like if
I say you then my lips are rounded and
they're protruded again
you you however
in Japanese
there is there is essentially
well there's there's no lip rounding
um but the best way to think about it is
probably just that in Japanese the lips
are generally speaking neutral
and there's no lip protrusion either so
it's not ooh but it's
so if I say
and there's
there's a little bit of what's called
lip compression in this particular sound
so kind of like the the corners of your
lips can come in a little bit but it's
it's much more of a
uh just think about the best way to
think about it is that you're not going
to be rounding your lips and you're not
going to be protruding your lips forward
so if I if I say you as in you in
English and then I say the equivalent
you in Japanese look at the difference
in my lips
you you you that's English and then if I
do the Japanese it's you you
so a mistake that a lot of Japanese a
lot of English native English speakers
make when they say the Japanese name
Ayumi for example there's a lot going on
here on there but one of the mistakes
that they make is that they say the U in
the middle
like in English you
and so they end up saying
uh uh you me a Yumi
but again it's not
Ayumi
it's
so in in my English pronunciation there
the pitch accent is also wrong
and there's there's a lot going on but
the best
how about you you yeah yeah it's the
same it's um
you would you wouldn't say you you would
say you you and again there's a little
bit of lip compression so your lips
might the corners of your lips might
come in a little bit but you just want
to avoid protruding your lips and you
want to avoid rounding your lips in the
Japanese uh sound now there's
the fourth vowel so
is also a little bit tricky too but
because there's so much information uh
that I'd like to cover in today's
presentation I'm going to skip over uh
it and for people that are curious they
can check out my lesson on vowels I've
got a couple lessons on vowels on my
pitch accent Series so let's just go on
to
this row of sounds now so
so
I guess the the first thing that I'd
like to cover is do you guys happen to
know where your tongue placement is when
you make a k sound
now most if you've never studied a pitch
accent or pronunciation rather uh oh hey
hey tiny bit of chaos thanks for
stopping in
um if you've never studied uh
linguistics
phonetics phonology then it's it's hard
to conceptualize where your tongue is
when you're saying the K sounds but it's
actually in this position so kind of the
back part of your tongue comes up and
touches the upper back part of your
mouth and
so if you try and make a k sound like
you should be able to feel
your tongue touching kind of like the
upper back part of your mouth and what
happens is the tongue touches up there
and then when you say the sound uh your
tongue is released and that's when the
air comes through
but
one cool thing one cool tip that we can
get to for these particular sounds I'm
going to lower my desk right now
oops
sorry I've got a lot of stuff on my desk
my desk is kind of freaking out
okay
okay let's lower it down slowly
dude's got the fancy desk yeah I've got
a herniated disc in my back so um if I
don't use a standing desk then I can't
get any work done
Okay so
now another interesting tip uh piece of
information is that
the K sounds and the g sounds are
essentially identical the only
difference
is that in you in the G sounds you are
using your vocal cords so if I say
if I make a k sound again you can feel
how your tongue is kind of touching the
upper back part of uh
of your of the top of your mouth again
that's a k sound right and if you put
your hands on your on your vocal cords
on your voice box you'll feel that they
don't vibrate it's just air coming out
but your vocal cords aren't vibrating so
again
but if you do the same thing and you
make a g sound
you'll feel that your vocal cords are
vibrating so the only difference between
the K sounds
and the g sounds is that again you're
using your voice box but here's the tip
that I wanted to share with everyone
um there are some instances in Japanese
in which when you're saying the G sounds
we talked about the tongue placement in
KNG a second ago again kind of I'll just
show it up real quick
so this is the tongue placement for the
K G sounds in Japanese but when you're
speaking at speed when you're talking
quickly in Japanese
this is more of a phonetics lecture but
it's still important yeah I'm trying to
break things down in a way that's kind
of easy to understand for most people
but the tip here is that if you're
speaking Japanese quickly there are
instances in which your tongue doesn't
actually come in full contact with your
mouth when you're making the G sounds so
the Japanese word for Mirror
and if I say it you know very
deliberately like I'm doing right now
kagami
that's a that's a hard stop my tongue is
actually coming into contact and you can
hear a very clear G sound
but if I speak quickly what happens is
there's a lot of native speakers that
will kind of slur the G sound and what
will happen is that the tongue will get
close to this position this contact
position uh uh up here but it won't
actually come in full contact and it
becomes kind of like this messy uh in
between excuse me in between sound kind
of like
so here the difference
again in the faster I say it it's
unnatural if I if I say it slowly with
with that kind of slurred sound but this
happens all the time in quick speech
people say
and you'll hear it with with other G
sounds as well so that's that's a good
uh tip to
to know for the excuse me for the G
sounds so now let's go ahead and go on
to
these sounds
so
there's there's so many interesting
things that I could cover for these
can you say in a fast sentence
so like I looked at the mirror
okay
um
so G sounds like K but it's deep in the
throat it's not so much that it's deep
in the throat it's just that you're
using your vocal cords okay so again
versus go
okay so um the thing that I wanted to
cover here is that
in the second sound here so
she she she she earlier we talked about
I've heard G pronounced like sometimes
well that might be a good interesting
point to cover actually let's go back to
that that real quickly
I've got a video up about this on
YouTube but I think it's it's a good
thing to cover
um
many times Japanese people will say like
but then they'll nasalize that g sound
as in
yeah and
um
yes this is what's known as sorry
I believe it's
yeah yeah
yeah exactly so this this is a
this is this is a phenomenon known as
and it's
it's got some very complicated rules and
the basic I encourage people when they
hear you know that nasalization in the G
sounds because G by itself actually
isn't a nasal sound like if I say got
if I say a g sound and even if I plug my
nose got got got got
it's the same right it doesn't change
whether I have my nasal the passage to
my nasal cavity open or not but then
again why why does why do people
sometimes say so this and not
why does it become nasal sometimes this
is known as
and it used to happen someone wrote the
kanji up in there um yeah
it's four spiral arms this is kind of
like
the quick explanation is that this used
to be much more common in Japanese and
there are some really complicated rules
for when you should and shouldn't use it
but the practical way to think about it
for Japanese speakers is that
this phenomenon of slowly uh or this
phenomenon of nasalizing your G sounds
even when there isn't a nasal sound
before it so like an N or an or an m
that's yeah
um this phenomenon is going away and
slowly and there's a lot of young people
that more often than not they won't do
any
so they won't nasalize their their G
sounds and I encourage Japanese Learners
to be aware of this phenomenon of G
sounds getting nasalized but just to not
worry about it because the rules are too
complicated and it looks like the
phenomenon might in disappear entirely
from Japanese and the relatively near
future and there's a whole bunch of
native speakers that don't do it anyway
so it's not
if you're not doing it it's not a matter
of oh you're being lazy and you should
you should do it because you'll sound
more native that way that's not true
you'll sound you can sound very very
native even if you don't do that
okay so uh let's go on to these sounds
so
earlier I talked about
lip placement and how uh in well how to
use your lips when speaking and the
thing that I stressed is that in
Japanese
the lips are relatively speaking neutral
and this is a pretty big import this is
this is true for
more or less across the board in
Japanese now there are there are some
sounds in Japanese in which you have to
use the lips like the M sounds or the P
sounds or uh the
the the B sounds because those are
bilabial or lip sounds in which you use
your lips but in a sound like this uh in
any of the S sounds you know
you don't really need to worry about
your lips at all and this is important
because if you're a native English
speaker then you're probably saying the
shh
the second sound in this row so that
this sound you there's a high
probability that you're protruding your
lips forward when you say this when you
say this sound because in English we do
this like if I say the word for if I say
she you know
uh pronoun for a a female or someone
that identifies that way if I say she
look look how my lips are protruded she
she
this doesn't happen in this this uh
sorry this sound right here your lips
are neutral so it's you know
so
you don't need to worry about your lips
generally speaking when speaking
Japanese so be careful when you say the
Japanese
let's see yeah this sound don't protrude
your lips if you don't protrude your
lips you'll sound more natural
okay cool let's go on to the Japanese
sounds or the togul so the touched
now this is an instance in uh where I
would like to use the graphics and that
be that's because the
placement for the tongue in the English
tea is different than in the Japanese
tea so what do I mean by this
in the English tea
I'm going to take this off real quick
and put up an english team notice how
the tip of the tongue is coming into
what's known as the alveolar Ridge so
that little tiny bump between or right
right behind the upper back front right
behind the upper teeth that little bump
the tongue is touching that little bump
it's not touching the teeth
okay
now this contrasts with the Japanese tea
in which the tip of the tongue
does touch the back of the Upper Front
Teeth
back of the upper
back of the yeah upper upper yeah front
teeth so
um again this this is the English tea
see where the tongue placement is and
this is the
Japanese tea again the tip of the tongue
is touching the back of the Upper Front
Teeth and then what's known as the blade
of the tongue so the the bit of the
tongue right but right behind the tip of
the tongue is touching the alveolar
Ridge so
it's not
that big of a difference in terms of uh
the way that you hear it but the
difference is slight and if you would
like your Japanese to sound as As
Natural as possible it's important to
know that again you're the tip of your
tongue should be touching the back of
your upper front teeth in the Japanese
sound and if you look for it you can
actually see a Japanese speaker's tongue
more
then an English speaker when a Japanese
speaker says uh the T sounds so if a
Japanese speaker says
you know like there's a word in Japanese
uh an adverb overwhelmingly
and it ends with
um
it was funny I uh
I had a Japanese friend that was
that said my Japanese teas didn't sound
like Japanese teas when I was studying
abroad and I was like what are you
talking about a t is a t and he was like
no I don't know like you're something
about your tongue like
it sounds a little bit off and I was
like my really and he said yeah try and
say this sound
and I remember when he slowly said it
and he got to the te
I could see a lot more of his tongue
than I was kind of expecting to uh from
my preconceptions of what a t sounds
like being a native English speaker
and I remember being surprised by that I
was like oh and I looked into it a
little bit and it turns out that yes the
Japanese tea is more forward in the
mouth
than the english team so this is good to
be aware of and this leads me actually
directly to
let's see is it more aspirated
oh that's a really good question as well
so um
we can answer that right now actually
so it's funny there was a meme that came
out
a couple of years ago it was about uh
it was about aspiration there was this
theory that okay
um there's not as much aspiration in
Japanese and so people don't exhale as
hard in Japanese as they do in English
and maybe that's the reason that covet
hasn't spread so much in Japan and so
there was this video that went viral on
Twitter of
this Japanese speaker and she was saying
um this is a pen yeah I got a tissue
don't worry I got it covered
so anyway
um she says
she speaks in English first and she says
you know this is a pen
pen
and you know there is a lot of
aspiration in t in English so if you say
so if you say the P sounds in English
the KT or P sounds
you know uh
kill kill kill kill or uh sorry it's
kind of violent
um
kangaroo kangaroo uh
well kale is just a good example kill
um peanuts
pen so you notice how the tissue moves a
lot however the ktnp Sounds in Japanese
aren't aren't nearly as aspirated as
their English counterparts so
um this is a really cool thing that you
can do if you're a native English
speaker because you don't know that
you're doing this when you speak but the
English
K sounds actually the amount of
aspiration that's involved it it gets
reduced dramatically if not in
it might disappear entirely if there's a
kit if there's an S before the k sound
and so
if I say again kill watch the tissue
kill
you can see it moving yeah
it moves but if I say skill
skill skill skill skill even if I say it
really loud
the tissue doesn't move and that's
because the S beforehand is transforming
the sound that the K makes and so the
Japanese K is kind of in between the two
in terms of how much air you exhale when
saying the sound
so again I'll say kill and skill back to
back a few times
kill
it's moving yeah
skill
kill
very interesting right if you've never
studied this
so again the Japanese is kind of in
between the two if I say um you know
uh
there's not as much um
aspiration the tissue doesn't move as
much now there are instances in Japanese
when there is aspiration
um it has to do more with when people
are like really stressing something or
what they're talking in kind of like a
a uh
a
an emotional Manner and so you know like
if I'm angry in English I might be like
God darn it you know and I might change
the way that I normally speak and then I
might aspirate more I might aspirate
less and the same thing is is true in
Japanese there are instances in which
again there will be more aspiration in
The ktnp Sounds in Japanese but
generally speaking you aren't exhaling
as much in Japanese in those three
sounds as you are in English so that
whole thing on Twitter you know the lady
saying
this is a pen versus it got a lot of
flack because people were like this is
so ridiculous there's no way that um
covet is spreading less because of
the Japanese language and also because
the lady was really emphasizing the you
know the the P sounds she was saying you
know this is a pen like
this is a pen you know like that but it
is true that if you say the word pen in
English versus Peng in Japanese you'll
exhale less air in the Japanese version
so maybe we can re recreate the meme
real quickly here
foreign
but I forgot that I was speaking
Japanese so
let me redo that
this is a pen this is a pen but if I
speak Japanese and I speak natural
Japanese it's going to be more like
Cordoba pen this
versus again this is a pen this is a pen
this is a pen it is true that there's
less aspiration in the Japanese ktnp
sounds okay so some questions coming in
I'd like to try and answer these really
quickly
um let's see uh
sorry I thought I saw something maybe
okay Logan can you recommend uh any
learning techniques for remembering
grammar and kanji I keep forgetting this
stuff um even when practicing every day
um I
I would say
that it's easier to remember words and
grammar points if you can remember them
within any within context that has
emotion attached to it attached to it
and what I mean by that is that
let me take these off screen real quick
um
there's a word in Japanese for
unsheathing your unsheathing your sword
and there's there's different ways that
you can say that in Japanese
so someone says can you talk about the G
sounds in Japanese I always hear it as
an N I talked about this earlier in the
Stream I would encourage you Cordova pin
this thank you very much for the Super
Chat very much appreciate that
um
I talk about the the G sounds earlier in
the Stream please re-watch that once the
stream is done I answer that question
specifically okay so uh
there is a sound in Japanese let's see
so the word in Japanese for sword is
Ken there are multiple ways that you can
say that but say it but one way to say
it is King
and there are different ways in Japanese
that you could say to take out your
sword you could say
or
that's take out your sword but if you
want to say unsheath then there's a
kanji compound for that which is said as
and
the reason that I remember that word is
because it was in an episode of Attack
on Titan and I was watching Attack on
Titan and looking up all the words in
this one episode that I didn't know and
I was able to
remember that word even only hearing it
once because I had the context of the
episode I think it was
it was either it was either autumning or
it was Zhang that said it
it was in one of the episodes
when they're chasing the female Titan
through the forest and again they say
Bakken you know there's no way that I
would ever remember if it was just on an
Anki flash card but because I had the
context of the anime and because I liked
that episode I was able to remember it
essentially immediately so if you're
having trouble remembering grammar or um
vocab I would encourage you to try and
find
um
instances of that word yeah that's the
kanji someone wrote it back again
um
there are instances
also exists interesting
um there are instances see I don't know
about though because it wasn't in the
anime but if you can find the word or
the grammar point in something that you
like or you make a mistake while
speaking that's even better because if
you make a mistake in front of a native
speaker and they correct you then you'll
get embarrassed for it you'll get
emotion attached attached to that memory
and you'll never forget it
so try and attach some emotion or some
context to the grammar points and the
vocab rather than just using
flash cards or whatever use flashcards
with some additional context okay so a
second ago we talked about how
the Japanese tea uh the tongue placement
is like this and you can see again the
tip of the tongue oh sorry that's the
English tea the Japanese tea is like
this with the tip of the tongue touching
the Upper Front
the back of the Upper Front Teeth
now what's interesting about this is
that
the same thing is true for the Japanese
n sounds so the Japanese
T sounds and the Japanese n sounds have
the same exact tongue placement and you
might be thinking well how does that
work if the tongue placement is the same
then shouldn't they sound the same and
the difference is that in the Japanese
oops
sorry I gotta put in the graphic really
quick I think that I got it in here one
second
the only difference is that in the
Japanese n sounds the passage to the
nasal cavity is open and so even if your
tongue is touching up against the back
of the Upper Front Teeth
air is traveling through your throat and
out through your nose so the tongue
placement is the same but the sound
sounds different because it's a nasal
sound and T is not a nasal sound
so let's see hopefully I can find that
really quickly
the presentation until
not uh sorry sorry guys I wasn't able to
prepare that one in time
um but again this is the Japanese T
sound now imagine that
n is the exact same except this little
bit right here is not coming into
contact with with this bit right here
this little passage is open and that's
what makes it different and but note how
in the Japanese
t and n again the tongue placement is
the same it's more forward than in the
um
than in the English n Sound or the
English T sounds in which the tip of the
tongue is touching the alveolar Ridge
okay
so maybe we can go on to
these sounds actually let's take a take
a break real quick because I'm going
pretty quickly and I'm using some fairly
um
intense terms weird question but I have
a huge problem let me see this uh making
outspoken Japanese and exposing myself
to a lot of spoken Japanese without CC
not only doesn't help but I feel like
I'm somehow regressing I would say
probably
just try and
here's here's maybe a good anecdote for
you
um I studied Japanese pretty intensely
throughout my teens and
fairly intensely for for like a 13 year
old anyway I thought I was okay at
Japanese then I also took one year of
Japanese when I was at University before
studying abroad
and despite this and despite the fact
that I was studying really intensively
during the first six months of study
abroad I felt like I wasn't really
making that much progress I was in the
same situation as you and I was thinking
I'm studying so much but I killed I
still kill scale I couldn't really
understand I still can't understand what
all these Japanese people around me are
saying
and so
um I I said to myself you know I wonder
if this is like a phase thing I wonder
if this will pass or I'm trying to
reorient the screen such that I can
there's a little bit more contrast
because the the background's white I
want to try and get the the graphics to
pop a little bit more on screen but what
happened is there was this weird moment
where it was six months into my studies
I went and I visited my my uh my cousin
who lives in Kolbe who lived in Kolbe at
the time
um
and we basically only spoke in English
for that week or whatever that we were
you know hanging out together and then
when I went back to Tokyo it was like my
mind because it had time to take a break
and reset a little bit when I went back
to Tokyo I suddenly felt like I
understood everything that people were
saying despite the fact that I hadn't
studied anymore and this is kind of a
long-winded way of saying I think that
there is kind of a critical mass moment
meaning that there's a very long time
where you feel like you don't understand
anything and then suddenly you feel like
you understand a whole lot this has
happened this happened to me
yeah you kind of like the switch kind of
finally flicks on
and uh this this happened to me and I've
heard other anecdotes of other people uh
going through similar things so um I
know that it can be a little bit
frustrating if you're studying really
hard and you're not making a lot of
progress
um but I would say
keep at it and you may find that you
wake up one day and suddenly it's like
oh wait a second
I can actually understand this like
yesterday it feel it felt like I
couldn't understand anything so keep
going I guarantee it gets better okay so
let's talk about these sounds
okay so as we talked about earlier in
Japanese uh the lips are neutral and
you've probably heard about this in your
Japanese classroom
but
the Japanese F sound so this one
you do not round you you do not
bite your lip as you would in the
English F sound so if I say
um forget
notice where how I bite my lip in the F
sound in forget f
forget forget
and this is because again in English the
lips aren't as neutral as they are in
Japanese but
we don't do this in Japanese because the
lips are neutral as we talked about
earlier so this whole lips are neutral
in Japanese this applies to a whole
bunch of sounds and if you try and
concentrate on keeping your lips neutral
then your Japanese will improve
um
dramatically this the naturalness of
your spoken Japanese will improve
dramatically because neutral lips
affects so many different aspects of the
language of the spoken language now
again you probably did already know that
you don't bite your lip when you're
saying the F sound but there's a tip
that I always like to tell people and
that's that there's a fair amount of
loan words in Japanese
so English words that have kind of
become loan words that have kind of
become Japanese words
um
and in these words if you're a native
English speaker even if you know and
even if you say uh the Japanese F sound
F sound correctly in Native Japanese
words
your mind will kind of switch back to
English mode a little bit when you say
the Japanese F sound in loan words now
what I mean by that this is if I say for
example what's a good word
um
uh so there's there's a fish
in Japanese uh it's like a puffer fish
or you know I think it's called a puffer
fish it's called
uh yeah it's a sometimes served as sushi
in Japan so again
notice how I'm not biting my lips
now even if I'm able to say it correctly
there's a chance that when you say that
same F sound in Lone words in Japanese
such as
Fernando
that you are reverting to the English
sound and that you're saying not
Endo but
who
florendo this used to happen to me all
the time and I've seen it in other
native speakers in English native
speakers as well so concentrate on
keeping your F Japanese sounds
consistent in both
uh Native
Japanese words but also loan words in
Japanese like if you say Final Fantasy
in Japanese and you say
and you and you're not conscious of it
you might end up saying you know
I've trained myself really hard on this
so it's it's hard for me to revert to
the English sound but
um just be careful of your your F sounds
in in loan words okay
that said let's go on to the
Mommy Mommy sounds so I'm gonna
basically skip over these because this
is generally speaking the the one row of
sounds where English and Japanese is
identical
the pronunciation of
the lip placement in the Japanese M and
the lit placement in the English M and
everything else about the sounds are
identical so the good piece of
information for this particular sounds
is that you don't need any information
you're already saying these sounds
correctly if you're a native English
speaker okay
now let's go on to these sounds so these
um I'm going to
talk about these a little bit in terms
of the mechanics of the sound what's
happening with these sounds so these are
what's known as Glides and what's
happening in in the Y sounds
is that
it's essentially like if you say the ya
sound essentially what's happening in
your mouth if I break it down in detail
it's you you start
you say a
a sound but you say the sound with your
tongue beginning in the E position
so you say you put your tongue in the
eat position
and you've got it ready there
but then you go from that position and
you say ah so you start with eat and
then you say ah and that's what creates
the Glide the ya sound so if I say it
really slowly yeah
yeah you can hear how it starts at e and
it ends with ah
[Music]
yeah
and this is why if you've ever seen
written Japanese
you might notice that people often um
drop the eat in instances in which
there kind of should be an eat
technically speaking so I'm going to
write this in chat real quick but um
for example
the word for or if you want to say like
no I don't want to do that in Japanese
then you could say this
yada
so that's spelled this way
uh sorry e
H yeah exactly exactly exactly
yada but as someone else just wrote the
funny animator Jim TV
oftentimes
uh in Japanese people will drop that
initial eat and they'll just say yada
yada and the reason for that is because
it's a little bit redundant in fast
speech in the beginning of the Y sounds
your tongue is already in the eat
position and so if you're trying yeah
exactly
uh that's that's why that e sound often
gets dropped because it's already in the
sounds so that's why that happens it's
pretty interesting right
so that's why again people say you know
yada or y'all
rather than yeah
so again good to know okay now
everyone's favorite
[Music]
the Japanese R sounds
um
yeah please
yeah stop spamming
um
[Music]
so the Japanese R sounds I think one of
the reasons that a lot of people have
trouble with these sounds is because
when people learn them they learn the
content they learn them in the context
of exactly what I just said the Japanese
R sounds when these are anything but R
sounds they are not R sounds and if you
try and conceptualize them as R sounds
you're already off to a bad start so I
apologize for saying the r sounds
but what's happening in these sounds is
it's the exact same thing that happens
when you say the word butter or better
and you notice how your tongue
let's see
your tongue is touching the alveolar
Ridge so I'm going to go back to the
English T sounds really quickly
um
so this this is the tongue placement for
the English T sounds and this is
actually also the tongue placement for
the Japanese R sounds
what happens when you say the Japanese R
sounds is that your the tip of your
tongue really really quickly hits the
alveolar Ridge so again this little spot
uh right between right behind the upper
back front teeth it really hits that
spot and it really quickly hits that
spot and then it flicks downward really
really quickly
so
um
and one of the keys is speed and if you
don't say it quickly then it'll sound a
little bit English but the other thing
that's important to realize is that you
you don't want to curl your tongue
backwards because not only will that
slow you down when you say the sound and
I should mention that I I have trouble
with the Japanese R sounds so I just
want to get that out of the way
but when you say these sounds uh I
paused my anime for this thanks for the
lesson hey I'm happy to help uh pandra B
pen Dragon thank you very much for the
super chop when you say these these uh
Japanese arsons you want to say them
very very quickly but someone
in the chat
uh said how do you pronounce
the N into R sound uh like in
bendy
and this is a really great question
because it's very very difficult now
what happens is again if if this is your
Upper Front Teeth if this if this is
your upper front teeth and then this is
your tongue what's happening in these
sounds is that the tip of your tongue
goes up and it hits it really quickly so
it's happening super quickly and it's
not
it's not this wind-up motion it's just
from here to here and down
really really really really quickly now
it's confusing because what happens in
an n Sound is that as we saw earlier the
tip of your tongue does come in contact
with uh your alveolar Ridge right and so
like if I say
that's an English n but again the
Japanese and it's just a little bit more
forward so
um
my tongue is already in this spot so if
I want to say the Japanese word for
bendy
or which is the word for
um
uh useful
so it's spelled like this
Ben bendy what happens is when you say
bet we won't cover that but when you you
say bet
and then you go from
you say you say bet
um
B
Endy
and so you put your tongue up against
the alveolar Ridge in the in the middle
of the word and rather than
removing your tongue
on you know uh
no longer become no longer being in
contact with the alveolar Ridge you you
you keep it up there and you you flick
your tongue down from the contact
position of
so it's not be
it's
bendy
again I'm gonna do that one more time
it's not bet
um
the it's bendy
you keep your tongue in the same contact
once your tongue comes in contact with
the contact position the alveolar Ridge
in
when you when you go from that to the
the r sound there's no reset in between
your tongue stays up there and then you
flick it down quickly and the reason a
lot of native English speakers have
trouble with with this sound is because
they don't know this and so they will
try and reset halfway through the sound
they'll say like okay Ben
B and it slows you down
but it's been the bendy so keep your
tongue up against there up against the
alveolar Ridge and go straight from
there down into the uh
the sounds so it's you could one way to
think about it is that
the you know the the Japanese R sounds
there's a touch and release
but if there's an sound preceding that
then the touch portion of the r sound
you don't do that you just do the
release of the of the r sounds okay and
this is true for you uh bendy uh sorry
it's my scroll shindi
okay sounds like you should flick the r
out after the in sound yep exactly that
is exactly correct okay
so uh horrible Corner hey Dugan how's it
going today good uh how about you guys
I'm having fun with this chat
um
now oh gosh
I once heard
uh kind of like r l and D yeah it's
I have two dedicated lessons to the r
sounds
um everything that I've been talking
about today I've been kind of going
through fairly quickly because there's a
lot of information but right here you
know Japanese pronunciation and Pitch
accent lessons at patreon.com I break
down everything that I'm talking about
right now
in much more simple clear organized
terms on my patreon series Japanese
phonetics if you're interested in that
so I've got two dedicated lessons on the
r sounds that are very methodical very
uh systematic and I slowly say okay this
is the tongue position this is exactly
what happens and again it uses those
same Graphics that we saw earlier with
Native recordings as well so I would
encourage anyone interested to check
those out now let's talk about
uh uh let's talk about both the O and
the sound a little bit so let's start
with the sound in the middle here so the
object marker in Japanese
now the
technically correct pronunciation of
this sound is just it's identical to the
Japanese
that we saw earlier with the vowels uh
so the last of these vowels this sound
you know oh this the pronunciation of
this and the pronunciation of this
technically speaking are the exact same
so if you buy like a Japanese
um pronunciation textbook then they'll
say you should pronounce them the exact
same but you may notice that um
Japanese speakers they often say this
sound kind of like whoa
almost like there's like a little almost
like there's a w before it or there's
like a little before it and it's like a
wool
so what's going on here and this is just
kind of
the a I believe I haven't looked into
this in a while but I I believe that
that that used to be the correct uh
pronunciation of the word but kind of
over time it's just evolved into the oh
but there are still many many people
that say well we'll
and it's good to know that because you
will almost certainly uh learn in the
classroom that it should always be said
as oh but then you'll go out and you'll
hear native speaking you'll hear natives
speaking Japanese and you'll sometimes
hear this
and it's like that's not what I learned
what's going on here and again it's just
this is
well that
It's tricky because it depends on the
surrounding sounds and so someone
someone wrote
and
it really depends
on it's it depends on the speaker it
depends on the situation it's it's quite
complicated but the the tip that I want
to give for this sound the Japanese
or is that you probably learned it as
but you're going to hear a fair amount
of native speakers say
with kind of like a A or like a W uh
small W sound before it well thank you
very much Isaac I can't recommend
Logan's patreon enough incredibly
helpful
really appreciate that
um so I
the simplest thing to do is to just
always say this uh this sound
the exact same way as you would say the
Japanese sound that's the simplest way
to do it and you'll sound native
but I actually kind of like the
sound it's got a little bit more kind of
character to it I think so I say both
um but it's really up to uh how much
time and effort you want to put into
that that sound in particular
okay now let's move on to uh this sound
the Japanese
so this is arguably the most complicated
sound in Japanese and I've got it's
either two or three lessons in my two or
three like 10 minute lessons in my video
series about about this sound because
it's so complicated this sound is
generally taught as just oh it's like an
n Sound but this sound is actually like
seven or eight different sounds
and what I mean by that is the
pronunciation of this sound changes
depending on the surrounding sounds
so
here's here's an example if I say
um
Tempo the Japanese word for tempo
let me just make sure I'm looking at uh
I'm
yeah so you know Tempo like as in music
Tempo then I would say Tempo Tempo
Temple or like a really really common
example is people say
right
and if you learned the let's see if you
learned uh this sound right here as an N
then you'll say
you'll say an N that turns into an m
but in the word gambate
you shouldn't pronounce it as an N that
turns into an M it's just pronounced as
an m so you say
[Music]
so it depends
on the surround on the sounds that come
after it and so again if if a if a b is
coming after this sound then then this
sound is set as an m
but if a
T is coming after this sound then it
said with the tongue in an end position
at the beginning of the mouth that's why
I said
10 10 pull earlier
or 10 10 10
this sound
changes depending on the surrounding
sounds and if I say
then it's an N but an N that's
articulated at the back of the mouth
and it's a little bit difficult for me
to
uh break this down in detail because it
really requires
in order to do it
concisely in a way that's easy for most
people to understand you really need
graphics and you really need like 20
minutes of time and that's why I spend
two dedicated lessons to this on my
patreon series but the main thing that I
want to stress here is that this is not
just an n and if you
if you think that it is just an n then
you'll end up making a lot of mistakes
in your Japanese it depends it's it's a
nasal version of the sound that comes
after it
this sound is a nasalized version of the
sound that comes after it okay
so
that's the best way to think about this
sound
um but you can pronounce it sometimes
with the tip of your tongue up against
the back of your Upper Front Teeth
sometimes you pronounce it at your lips
sometimes you pronounce it at the back
of your mouth sometimes you pronounce it
at the real back of your mouth but then
the other thing is that we have words
like
in which
people are like
wait it's an n
but then shouldn't it be
fun Inky what's going on here and again
this is because it depends on the
surrounding sounds and another version
of this this another way to pronounce
this sound is as a nasalized vowel so if
I say the Japanese vowels you know I can
plug my nose and they won't sound weird
because vowels in isolation
are not nasal sounds so I'm going to
plug my nose and say each of the um
each of the Japanese vowel sounds
oh
are you ill it's they're the same right
but in a word like
what's happening is you're saying that
what happened you pronounce this as
essentially
an e sound in which your nasal cavity is
open
so it's anything but an n
it's a vowel it's a nasalized vowel
so again the thing that you really want
to you know Zayn as well it's the same
you don't pronounce it as Zane you
pronounce it as vein vein and you
briefly nasalize that in the middle of
the word but you don't let your tongue
come in contact with any part of your
mouth you just say it as a nasalized
vowel and if again if if this is a
little bit intimidating I break this
down
in detail in in across two or three
lessons on my patreon series and there's
actually like drills that I give and I
say start start by saying this okay now
tweak your tongue position to be like
this a little bit okay now tweak it a
little bit more to be like this and I
slowly walk everyone through the
um
the various pronunciations of this sound
again the uh the thing that I really
want to stress is that this sound is a
lot more complicated than you think and
if you just uh assume that it's oh it's
an N it's just an N you might be making
a lot of mistakes I did for years as
well so
um just really good to be aware of okay
so um at this point I want to take a
bunch of questions later on but
um
okay let's see psyche I'll say this
is in your pitch accent series you say
that the second to last more of nakadaka
verbs is always uh accented in the in
the dictionary form but the cotton is
accented can you explain uh yes I'll get
to that later
um the very short answer is that it's
because
the second to last about the second to
last sound in that word is a special
sound it's a vowel it's a trailing vowel
so the down step shifts back one more I
talk about that in the in the series
okay so let's
um shift from
pronunciation into pitch accent and then
we can take a bunch of questions about
either uh JP do you mind uh taking care
of these comments
um thank you we can then take a bunch of
questions at the end on both
pronunciation and Pitch oxim so I did
have a little bit of uh extra time to
prepare for this part of the series so
or this part of the lecture rather so
the question that I I often hear people
say is it's not beneficial to study
pitch oxen it's a little bit too
um
too complicated or you can you can be
people will understand what you're
saying even if you never start even if
you never study a pitch accent and this
is true and
but if this is true then why would I why
would I even teach this why would anyone
ever study pitch accent and the reason
for this is because if you do study
pitch accent it will make your Japanese
sound significantly more natural and
what I mean by this is
so so the quick answer is you should
study pitch accent if it's important to
you to sound as natural as possible if
you just want to be able if you just
want people to be able to understand
what you what you're saying and you
don't care about
having a an accent that sounds pretty
foreign then it's not important to study
pitch accent so it really comes down to
your personal goals for me I always
wanted to sound as natural as possible
and so when I learned that pitch accent
was a thing I was like
I want to study this that my Japanese
sounds better
so okay
and here's a really good example of this
a lot of people because they never study
pitch accent they don't realize how many
pitch accident mistakes that they make
and
the best way to see if
if you are speaking Japanese
here's a good test that you can do can
you say the words Japan
Japanese language and Japanese people
can you say these three pretty basic
Japanese words with the correct pitch
accent again Japan
Japanese Japan Japanese language and
Japanese people this is a very easy test
to see is my pitch accent good
so you probably know how to say the how
to say the word for Japan which is which
I have spelled out uh
uh here sorry
uh between bendy and you clarified a lot
thank you hey it's my pleasure yeah
great thank you very much for the Super
Chat uh Rosie
so uh
sorry I'm going to delete delete this
comment yesterday because this is this
is a test that I prepared
uh please sorry I'm gonna
this is meant to be a test for people
that haven't studied pitch accident so
please don't type the answers if you
know the answers such that the people
who who don't know can test their
Japanese okay yes please please stop
please stop
okay
so you probably know how to say this
word
right it sounds like this okay
now but what about the word Japanese
language
this is how it's spelled
but how do you pronounce it
think about it a little bit to yourself
and maybe try and pronounce it out loud
remember
this is the word this is the pitch
accent for
Japan Nihon okay
so what's the pitch accent for
Japanese the Japanese language
now what a lot of people do is they say
okay well there's an accent on the whole
in
so it must be
nihongo with the accent being in that
same spot right if if it's um
if it's on the whole in the home then
it's probably on that same hole in in
this word so it's probably
but this is wrong it's not nihong it's
not it's
a okay it's not
so if you didn't know that
then this is
yeah you really do need to treat the
separately yeah yeah so if you got it
right that's great
um this is something that a lot of
people who've never studied pitch accent
um they often get wrong and I got this
this wrong for a very long time as well
until I started studying pitch accent
okay so again please do not uh type out
the answer for the next word
but okay now we're going to move on to
Japanese people
so
this is the word this is how you spell
the word for Japanese people so again
uh the accent for Japan it's it's like
this
and then for Japanese language it said
like this
so I wonder what the pitch accent
pattern of Nihon of of this word is I'm
not going to say it
so try and pronounce it by yourself real
quickly is it is it hmm
and if you can't tell the difference
between those
um
that might be a good reason to study
pitch accent
so the correct answer is that it's
different from both from either of the
two answers so it's not
either of the two previous answers it's
okay so the down step is on the the on
the uh G
so
what we have is
knee sorry I should start here I guess
um
and if you've never studied pitch accent
there's a fairly high possibility that
you might assume that they're all kind
of like Nihon and that you might and if
you make this assumption
unconsciously you might end up saying
again
um
you might end up saying nihongo or you
might end up saying
but but this is incorrect
um they're they're completely different
and if you're unaware of this
you might be saying these with the wrong
pitch accent pattern especially if
you're a native English speaker
okay Logan I understand that you
maintain a higher pitch when saying
nihongo but either way I notice a slight
descendant pitch on the gold syllable
with respect to Hong please explain so
this is a phenomenon known as the uh
gradual drop in pitch and I discussed
this in detail in my pitch accent series
the short answer
is that
when you speak and it's very difficult
to notice this if I don't put Graphics
up on screen and I didn't prepare
graphics for this for this presentation
because I didn't anticipate on hearing
it or uncovering it rather but when you
speak in your native language if I speak
in English
very often I'm going to begin a phrase
with a relatively high pitch and end the
phrase with a relatively low pitch and
the reason for this is because you
inhale air before you start speaking
and as you speak you exhale air right
when you're speaking you're exhaling
and if you speak a lot you're going to
run out of air okay and so
the more air that you run out of the
lower your voice is going to get in
pitch and the reason for that is because
the way to make a high pitch is to
push out a lot of air very quickly
and but as you run out of air it's
impossible to maintain that high pitch
so your voice gradually drops in Pitch
the difference between a very easy way
to think about it is that when you're
when you're speaking with a low pitch
you're speaking the the rate at which
you're exhaling air is slow and when
you're speaking at a high pitch the rate
at which you're exhaling is high and if
you take in a big deep breath to say
something to say a long sentence
naturally what will happen is that the
beginning of that phrase will be
High and the end of that phrase will be
low
relatively speaking and so even in a
flat word like
the same thing happens relatively
speaking you have a little bit more air
in your mouth at the beginning of the
word so it is it is low high high but
then what happens is
you just naturally have a little bit
less air in your in your lungs as you're
saying the words so whether it's a one
word phrase or whether it's a sentence
generally speaking there's a subtle drop
in Pitch that occurs over time and again
I I break this in I break this down in
detail
in about for about 10 minutes with
graphics and Native recordings on my
pitch accent series I would highly
encourage you to check that out if
that's something that that you
um are
again if you're interested in learning
more about the gradual drop in Pitch
okay why is the pitch missing for nihong
in the Apple dictionary it's therefore
the reason might be that you're looking
at not nihong but Nippon
that might be why okay but it's hard to
say for sure okay so but we just saw how
the pitch accent for
how they're all different
now what happens is people ask me all
the time they say oh but this means that
I have to look up the pitch accent for
every single word then oh God like
that's
that's so
that makes me lose my motivation that's
so much extra work just to sound a
little bit more native
but the good news is that you can learn
a bunch of little rules that you can
once you know the rule
you'll immediately know the correct
pitch accent for like a hundred words so
I'm what I'm going to do now
is I'm going to introduce a couple of
these rules and again keep in mind I
talk about like I don't know 20 or 30 of
these in my pitch accent series we're
going to just cover a couple of them now
okay so one of these rules is called the
minus three rule
and I'm going to try and break things
down
um I'm going to try and break things
in a easy to understand way
right here okay so
as a native English speaker
you kind of unconsciously have little
rules for how to pronounce words in your
head and when you come across a word
that you've never seen before you
unconsciously assume that the word will
have this particular pitch accent and
that's why
if a native English speaker sees the
word for
the Japanese City
Osaka Osaka they won't say Osaka they'll
say Osaka Osaka because they they've got
rules that they're unconsciously playing
by right all Native English speakers
unless unless they're studying Japanese
they'll say Osaka they won't say Osaka
they'll say Osaka and if if they say the
word for uh Yokohama they'll say
Yokohama
and if they see the word for uh Kawasaki
they'll say
Kawasaki there are unconscious rules
that there are rules that you're
unconsciously playing by okay as a
native English speaker and there are
also rules that native Japanese speakers
unconsciously play by now one of these
rules is called the minus three Rule and
the basic idea of this rule is that
if a noun in Japanese
has a down step or an accent in it then
generally speaking it's going to occur
on the third to last beat of that word
okay so what do I mean let's start
looking at some examples of this
this is a made-up word that I just made
up
sorry ma do
right now if I showed this to a Japanese
speaker and I didn't have this pitch
accent graph above it then they would
probably say this pitch hacks and graph
they would say
um
I would probably pronounce it as
madokasaki because this is again this
rule that native speakers unconsciously
play by if a noun has a has a an accent
generally speaking it'll occur three
Beats from the end of the word
so we'll keep this in mind as we look at
a bunch of uh
loan words
so and this is true for many nouns in in
Japanese that are loan words so how do I
say
so this is the Japanese word for banana
right
banana banana now notice how
if I say this word in English
the accent
well thank you very much for uh the
Super Chat Bonsai Harmony do you have
any exercises to train pronunciation
problems like bendy I understand what
you explained but still can't do it
right
um I don't have an exercise for that
specifically but in my pitch accent and
pronunciation series there are
um actually there are some exercises
that I recommend in the r sounds here's
one of them
um
I'm gonna take this off screen really
quickly one thing that you can do to
train yourself to say the r sounds
correctly is that you can practice
saying them with the tongue in the
contact position
so start with your tongue already
touching your alveolar Ridge as in
and then just flick it down and exhale
like
and if you practice that a bunch and
then you try and say
Ben the Bendy
that'll help that should help that's one
of the exercises that I recommend okay
going back here
if I say the English word for banana
Where's the accent banana banana banana
it's in the middle of the word right
banana banana
but in Japanese
it's not on the middle of the word it's
on the third to last beat of the word
banana banana why is this this is
because in the same way that a native
English speaker will look at the word
Osaka and they'll say Osaka because
there are rules that they're
unconsciously playing by when they speak
native Japanese speakers play by the
minus three rule when they speak
and so most English loan words when
Japanese speakers play them say them
rather sorry
regardless of whether where the accent
is in the original word
generally speaking it'll shift to the
third to last Mora in the Japanese word
so again even though it's banana
in English it's banana in English in
Japanese
here's the rule remember this in most
Japanese English loan words these these
foreign words that have turned into
Japanese words if the word has an accent
it occurs on the third to last Mora the
third to last beat of the word this is a
very important rule
banana so let's take a look at a bunch
of examples of this
again in English the word for bathroom
is bathroom and the accent is on the
bath bath bathroom but in Japanese it's
basurun
right
on the third to last Mora the third to
last beat of the word there are
exceptions to this
and I I break them down in detail how to
anticipate exceptions but
um
let's keep looking
so this is an example of a word that
happens to be the same in English and in
Japanese in terms of where the accent is
okay
uh
let's keep going but again uh third to
last Mora third to last beat of the word
desk
okay
fruits
third to last beat of the word okay
let's keep going in English we would say
cameraman cameraman with the accent on
the cat camera man right cameraman but
in Japanese again
third to last Mora of the word
uh keyboard in English we would say
keyboard Accent on the key but in
Japanese again it's Ki boldo
third to last Mora third to last Mora of
the word third last beat of the word
uh orange not
orenji but orenji
okay again it's that same third to last
Mora
yogurt
it's not
but yo Guru
third to last Mora of the word one more
oh sorry that was that was the last one
so again remember
generally speaking in in English loan
words and Japanese if the word has an
accent then that accent is going to
occur on the third to last beat of the
word so someone just asks so someone
just asked asked do and small count as
moras and uh they do but they they can
break the rule and what I mean by that
is
um
there are special sounds in Japanese
there are four of them and I break this
down in detail in my lesson but um
there are some most of the exceptions
that exist to this minus three rule this
minus three rule up here they occur when
the third to last Mora is one of the
four special sounds so like the Japanese
word for supermarket
is not super with the accent occurring
on the
in Supermarket it occurs on the fourth
to last Mora which is the first beat of
the word it's
right and the reason that it's it shifts
back
is because the third to last Mora of the
word is a long vowel it's a special
sound there are four special sounds and
if the third to last Mora is a special
sound then nine times out of ten the
down step will just shift back one more
Okay and like another good example is
the Japanese word for London
um
we we don't say
we say right
it's not on the third to last tomorrow
it's on the fourth to last Mora because
the is a special sound so it shifts back
one more there's two other special
sounds
um uh yeah uh
yeah okay uh
so just remember
[Music]
the overwhelming majority of
circumstances in
loan words the down step is going to be
on the third to last Mora of the word
and if it's uh if the word has a down
step and if the if the third to last
moral of the word the third to last beat
is a it has it's a special sound then
it'll just shift back one more one beat
okay and I talk about again all the
special sounds in detail in my pitch
accent series but let's let's keep
talking about Pitch accent okay
um so
the two kinds of verbs slideshow okay
here we go so
in Japanese
generally speaking there are two kinds
of verbs
in terms of pitch accent there are
flat verbs and then there are verbs in
which the accent occurs
on the second to last beat of the word
okay
so let's let's look at a bunch of
examples of this
so to open in Japanese is spelled like
this it's okay to akedu okay this is a
hair bong pattern so it does not have a
down step it's not uh can't do it's just
okay okay
so this is
it's uh accentless it's it's
this is one of the two types now the
other type is this this is the word for
close in this word
it's the down step occurs on the second
to last beat of the word as in
Japanese if a verb has a down step then
almost always the down step will occur
on the second to last beat of the word
so we just saw how in the minus three
rule
this is for
nouns in Japanese that have down steps
and then this is also specifically for
loan words but okay that's that's one
kind of word let's talk about a
different kind of word let's talk about
verbs there are two kinds of verbs verbs
without accents and verbs sorry uh verbs
with accents like that and then verbs
without accents like this
but if the verb does have an accent then
nine times out of ten actually much more
frequently than that the down step is
the accent the down step is going to
occur on the second to last beat of the
word Okay so
okay let's let's keep looking at a
couple of examples to live low high low
again second to last beat of the word
okay
now to decide this is a flat one it
doesn't have a down step and this is
this is really important because if
you're a native English speaker
um
there's a high possibility high
probability that you're saying all verbs
in Japanese with accents but only some
verbs in Japanese have accents so it's
not
but
okay if you say kimero
that sounds very very foreign despite
the fact that
um there are verbs in Japanese like
the structure of this verb sounds pretty
similar to the structure
or it looks pretty similar to the
structure of this verb right but they're
pronounced very differently
does have an accent but kimeru does not
have an accent okay so there's two kinds
of verbs again
one with accents and one without accents
and if the verb does have an accent nine
times out of ten it's going to occur on
the second to last beat of the word
to stand out against second to last beat
of the word
to hold again second to last beat of the
word
second to last beat of the word
to change
this is a flat verb okay so no accent
to stop
no accent
U
so kind of like to to receive to sorry
hmm
yeah to be attended to attend to
it's a little bit difficult to translate
this one but this is I'm just showing
like uh this longer verb up here
so that you know that even in longer
verbs if the longer verb has a has an
accent it's still going to occur on the
second to last beat of the word okay
okay
right and I'm talking about the
dictionary form so there are verbs that
do have accents and verbs that don't
have accents again I'm I'm trying to
reinforce this through repetition if the
verb does have an accent it's going to
occur nine times out of ten on the
second to last moral of the word
now you some of you might be thinking
well what about the Japanese word for
like go home
what's happening there kairu it's not
happening on on the second to last it's
happening on the third to last or the
you know the first beat of the word or
like to go inside it's happening on the
not the second to last but the third to
last
and these are exceptions to the rule
that I just explained okay what's going
on here is that the second to last Mora
is a trailing vowel
if the second to last moral of the word
the second to last beat is a vowel then
that down step is going to shift back
one beat so it's not
but and it's not but
okay so if a word two types of verbs
ones without down steps and ones with
down steps in this group nine times out
of ten the down step occurs in the
second to last beat of the word
but if the second to last speed of the
verb is a noun then it'll just shift
back one more and like
is another example of this
it's not kangaeru but and so someone
asked earlier uh there was a question
I talked about this there was a question
specifically about this in the comments
section
um someone said
sorry I can't find the comment right now
but that that's a perfect example of
what I'm what I was just talking about
because the second to last beat of the
word is an eh it just shifts back one
more
uh
that's that's a good that's a good point
that's a an exception to the exception
so
um
yeah so I think actually
sorry more
[Music]
oh sorry I was reading that wrong anyway
we're starting to kind of look at real
real real uh
like one in a hundred kind of exceptions
and for because most people watching it
won't benefit to break down every small
exception it's better to just
concentrate on on the the large the the
rules at large because again it's like
if you remember this
then your Japanese pitch accent batting
average it'll go up you'll still make
some mistakes you'll still swing
sometimes and Miss because there are
exceptions to the rules
but if you remember this and you didn't
know about it before then your pitch
acts on average
in general will go up so we want to
memorize these big rules that have a big
impact okay
yeah we'll get it right most of the time
your batting average will improve okay
so let's keep going so earlier we talked
about how there are two kinds of verbs
um
there are verbs that do have accents and
verbs that don't have accents right
but then many of you are probably asking
well how do I know if a verb has an
accent or not
do I have to look up all the verbs then
like one by one and
the there are some verbs that you will
have to look up but there's a ton of
verbs that you can memorize the pitch
accent just by knowing a couple of
Tricks so like a really good example of
this is um
let me find it the word to stand out
yeah right here I made a YouTube video
about this a while back but for those
that didn't happen to see that video
every single verb in Japanese that ends
with
every single one of them without
exception
it will have a down step and that down
step will occur on the second to last
Mora so
to hold Matsu to wait
to
be useful every verb in Japanese and
there's more that end with will have an
accent and it will occur on the second
to last Mora there's a bunch of verbs
there's a bunch of rules like this again
these these great rules where it's like
you memorize the rule you memorize one
rule and suddenly you know the pitch
accent of many words
so pitch accent is intimidating because
you you ha you initially think oh God I
have to memorize the pitch oxen for
every single word but that's not true
that's a completeness uh misconception
you memorize the important rules and
then very very quickly your Japanese
batting average again goes up you'll
still make mistakes I still make
mistakes but if you're you remember like
10 or 15 rules 20 rules if you're if you
want to get kind of more into it then
you'll you only have to study pitch
accent for a little bit of time in order
to see some massive results okay so
we're going to look at another one of
these rules right now
just a second ago one of the things I
said was how do we know if a verb has
has a um
there are two kinds of verbs verbs that
do have pitch accent verbs that do have
accents and verbs that don't have
accents but how do we know if the verb
how do we know which family the verb
belongs to and again we saw that if the
verb ends with it's always going to be
on the second class tomorrow but there's
another one for verbs that end with
generally speaking there's a couple of
exceptions to this but verbs that end
with
generally speaking they won't have
accents to them okay so let's look at
some examples of this
the Japanese word to fly it's not it's
not
it's
high thank you very much for the Super
Chat Batman really appreciate it so
bu if it ends with it probably doesn't
have an accent
what else
the Japanese verb to call to call
someone
it's not yobu it's
ends with so there's no accent so both
to fly and to call they end with book so
there's no accent let's keep going
the Japanese word to play or to hang out
it is not
native English speakers myself included
my past self included I used to
mispronounce this really really badly I
would say
it's not asobu it's there's no accent
again it ends with book so you don't say
it with an accent let's keep going
uh yeah there are exceptions but again
those are exceptions and you don't worry
about the small exceptions until you've
already learned the rule so let's keep
let's let's see more more examples of
the rule okay so Kerry
it ends with boo so it's not hakobu it's
hakobu okay
my notable to learn it ends with so
there's there's no there's no um accent
and
not able to line up it's not not Abu
it's not Abu okay
so again generally speaking most of the
time if a verb ends with boo and you
haven't memorized the individual pitch
accent of that verb then it's it's safe
to assume you'll get it wrong sometimes
but it's safe to assume that the verb
will not have a it will not have an
accent now there are a couple of
exceptions to this okay so one of them
is to choose it's
so it does have an accent another common
exception is to scream okay
and then one final common exception is
so to be happy or to be kind of filled
with joy
of the
ten or so verbs that we just saw that
end with blue
the majority of them
and with blue
so it's
and there there are more that that
didn't make this list there are more
verbs that end with so again remember if
a verb ends with it won't have an accent
let's go through all of these one more
time okay
so to fly
no accent
to call someone you'll be
to play
oh sorry someone just did a Super Chat
gold Thunder oh hey what's up dude thank
you very much for the uh
for the uh Super Chat really appreciate
that
uh
okay uh let's keep going
cool
to line up
it's flat no accent and then the three
the three uh good to know Exceptions
there are a few more that are a little
bit less common like and stuff like that
but I'd rather not that one's
pretty rare so I'm gonna skip over that
exception and we'll just do the three
common exceptions so
if you remember these three exceptions
and then just remember that most verbs
in Japanese that end with boo are flat
you immediately improve your Japanese
pitch accent uh again batting average
right uh party up thanks for the videos
hey my pleasure thank you very much for
stopping in
um
I'm kind of curious I've been going for
a while uh okay
okay let's keep going
oh okay that okay that was that was the
last uh point that I really wanted to
cover uh in in today's presentation and
we've been going for does anyone know
how long this uh live stream has been
going uh I started at 11 so oh geez yeah
almost two hours at this point
okay
so we've seen we've seen a bunch of
rules we've seen a bunch of good to know
tips
um and the thing that I want to just
stress again
um well actually the last thing that I
wanted to cover there's there's one more
thing I wanted to cover
a lot of people
tell me
what I said earlier uh they say
learning pitch accent isn't worth it
because it's it's so overwhelming
there's so many things to remember like
I have to look up the pitch auction for
every single word that's that's so um
that takes away all of my motivation I
don't want to study pitch ox and if I
have to do that so hopefully just now by
looking at a couple of useful rules so
like the minus three rule the two
categories for for verbs Rule and then
also the rule we disproved that myth we
showed that if you memorize a few useful
rules you don't have to memorize the
pitch accent for
every single word you can memorize a few
rules and immediately know the pitch
accent for a bunch of verbs or a bunch
of words in Japanese you don't memorize
the pitch accident or individual words
you memorize the rule and then if you if
you want to the exceptions to the rule
it really depends on how far you want to
go with your studies okay
so hopefully we disproved the notion
that you have to look up the pitch
accent of every single word now what
happens a lot of the time is that I
often have students that say
oh uh Hey Libra Elementary
thank you very much uh celebrate the
first Super Chat okay sweet I guess
do I press this or something sorry I
don't know well thank you very much for
the Super Chat how do I internalize
those rules so well I would like to say
that one really good way of doing that
is to go over to my patreon series over
on
let's go over to my Japanese pitch
accent series on patreon because I
structure the lessons such that the
rules are reinforced what we just did is
we took about two hours and we crammed
in a bunch of information right we said
look at this this is cool look at this
this is cool look at this this is cool
but there was so much information right
so
in order to process all this information
if you if you don't take some time to
review this information you're probably
going to forget a fair amount of it
right so one thing that I would
encourage everyone to do is to
re-watch this live stream once it's done
if you don't know the rules already
but someone said are there any books
that you recommend to learn the rules so
the whole reason that I made my pitch
accent and pronunciation series is
because there are a bunch of really good
books out there for learning pitch
accent and pronunciation and I've got a
couple of them right here right like
the shin makes
so like the shin Makai Japanese pitch
accent dictionary this is one
um and then this is another one the NHK
pitch accent dictionary
but these are really really thick books
and all the rules are written in
Japanese
and they're books so
they're incredible resources if your
Japanese is already at an extremely high
level and you don't need native
recordings
but if you're learning Japanese you
probably do need native recordings and
you probably do need to see Pitch accent
Graphics too and you probably need to
have the rules explained to you not in
Japanese but in English so that's what I
try to do with my pitch accent series I
tried to create the resource that I
wanted when I learned about Pitch accent
because I learned Japanese is a pitch
accent language and I was like what is
what is pitch accent and I started doing
all this research and all the research
that I did
it brought me to books like these these
Japanese books that I couldn't yet
understand you know I was like a year
maybe two years into my Japanese studies
and I couldn't read sorry I shouldn't
show the inside of this book but I
couldn't understand the high level
Japanese Linguistics terms linguistic
terms that are used within this book
so I I had to go out and find the
limited number of English books on this
topic so like one really good example is
the sounds of Japanese by Dr Timothy J
Vance another really good example is the
phonology of Japanese by uh I think it's
Lawrence LeBron there's a few really
good English books on this topic but
in my experience
um most of these books are for people
that have already studied
Linguistics and are familiar with
Linguistics terms
and then the second thing that makes
that can make some of these resources
um a little bit daunting for beginner
Learners is that
there's there's often a book and then
there's a CD but in this current day and
age you don't really I believe that it's
it's more effective to just watch a
video
that where someone explains that the the
concept the rule in easy to understand
English then says here's the graphic and
then
plays the native recording after that so
you don't have to like read the book and
then go over to the CD and then read the
book then go over the CD you just watch
a single video that breaks the whole
thing down
so that's what I tried to do with my
paychecks and pronunciation series I
tried to take all this information that
I learned from my classes at uh you know
the University of Washington at Ko
University and from all these these
books that I I spent Years Learning and
I tried to condense all of the core
information into these short lessons
that are about 10 minutes long each with
easy clear English and high quality
native English recordings the native
Japanese recordings from a trained
native speaker so that's what I tried to
do someone again answer someone said is
there like a book that I can use to to
to learn these rules and again there are
like again the sounds of Japanese by Dr
Timothy J Vance is a fantastic resource
I learned so much from that resource
it's it's it's incredible I wouldn't be
where I'm at without that resource
um and if you're interested in Pitch
accent I would encourage you to check it
out it's a great resource
um
and maybe it would be beneficial to also
check out my patreon pitch accent series
because again it's
a lot of the same information that you
can find in in many of these these books
or many of these uh high level
university courses that are meant for
oftentimes Japanese speakers who want to
become like announcers or something like
that I tried to break everything down in
very easy clear
clear easy to understand English and I
tried to create the resource that I
wanted to have when I was studying
Japanese pronunciation and Pitch accent
so we got a bunch of questions you know
from people earlier like well how do you
say
um
convenient in Japanese bendy
this is a very common question because
so many people struggle with it and so I
answer the question
specifically in the series with graphics
with examples because again that was a
question that I had I took all these
questions that I had when I was learning
Japanese I put them up in video form
with Native recordings and graphics and
that kind of thing
and then I teach it in a way such that
the information reinforces itself in
each lesson so I I'll say here's the
information
here's here's a bunch of examples of
that information
now here are the same examples but in
with Native recordings
and then here's kind of like my two
cents like maybe two two good two or
three good things to know about this and
then here's the wrap up
so we reinforce the information multiple
times throughout the lesson and then
on my series there are also um
there are like PDF tests that you can
use to test yourself of the knowledge
there are also Anki decks with Native
recordings inside them so that you can
test yourself and reinforce uh the
things that you're not so good at
um it's it's a very high quality fleshed
out resource and if you're interested in
learning more about Japanese
pronunciation and Pitch accent again I
would highly encourage everyone to check
out my my series patreon.com
I cover a lot of the same things that I
I talked about today here but I do it at
a much slower calm pace and it's just a
little bit easier to follow there today
I wanted to just do kind of like an
information dump like let's get a bunch
of information out there for people that
have time and want to learn a bunch of
really cool interesting things about
Japanese okay so I got to get going
fairly soon it's it's probably been
about two hours at this point
um but before I do go
how about this how about let's try and
answer some questions
um
that you guys might have related to
Japanese pronunciate pronunciation
pronunciation and Pitch accent okay okay
whoa whoa whoa okay uh 25 bucks so thank
you very much thank you so much for this
lesson it's great to go back and
reinforce those Basics and give us those
aha moments not just to correct bad
habits but to help more advanced
Learners understand why they're doing
something right hey it's my pleasure
thank you very much for that Super Chat
and uh gold Thunder again wow thank you
very much thank you for the second
donation and wow yeah 25 bucks wow jeez
that's crazy thank you so much ma'am
um I'm using consudo for self-study does
it do pitch accents right at all
um I'm unfamiliar with that resource so
I cannot uh give an informed answer
um I I apologize for that what is the
best way to look up the correct pitch
accent of a word this is a great
question
go to YouTube and type in Dogan Japanese
uh
actually
I I haven't
I have an episode on my pitch accent
series I think it's on YouTube as well
but it's um
episode seven
I take an entire episode in my series
and I say here's a bunch of free
resources that you can use to look up
the pitch accent of a word I'm going to
type a couple of them in chat right now
um let's see
okay
here's one
uh
okay
and here's another one
for though
so that's two resources that you can use
oftentimes
um the resources uh
sometimes they'll be wrong and that's
why you want to typically use two to
make sure that um
make sure that uh they both have the
same information or you can get like a
pitch action dictionary you know like
this and there's there's an NHK uh
pitch accent app that you can get for
your iPhone as well I believe
um and that's a great resource as well
for looking up those individual accents
but maybe not so useful for trying to
learn the rules I'm not sure I don't I
don't uh have that I've always used
different resources another one that you
can use is the Apple built-in dictionary
that's very good as well
okay
um
let's see uh okay
someone asked another question uh
I know this isn't necessarily pitch
accent related but how do I present
prevent burnout with me in Japanese I
feel myself losing motivation a lot and
it usually ends in detriment I'll tell
you what um before I answer this I'm
going to make myself a coffee real quick
I'm starting to lose lose steam so give
me give me one second I'm gonna make
myself a coffee
actually I gotta
I need to uh warm up my coffee machine
so maybe I'll do that first my short
answer for how do you uh what do you do
when you're about to when you feel
yourself burning out is I say don't try
and work through the burnout take a hard
break take a hard break I I did a little
bit of a reading on this topic the other
day and
um the information that I found that I
thought was pretty interesting was it's
no coincidence that all the world's
major religions have dedicated days each
week where you do nothing
and that's because
all the world's religions account for
the fact that humans can't go full steam
all the time you have to take breaks
right so whether it's you know
Christianity or Judaism or um uh
I think there's some in Buddhism as well
but also
um you know Islam
uh
there are there are each one of the
world's major religions has days have
days where you're you're meant to take a
break where you're you're supposed to
not work
and that's that's because again humans
humans are able to work harder after
they've had a good break now this isn't
it this isn't an excuse to
um
so just lie on the LIE on the sofa all
the time but it is an excuse to take a
break if you've been working hard and so
this is why I do recommend that people
who have um been studying really hard
um
to take a hard break be like I'm not
okay six days out of a week or maybe
five days out of out of every week I'm
going to study Japanese pretty hard but
I'm not going to hate myself for taking
a break on Saturdays and Sundays I think
that's actually the more effective
approach
great movie thank you very much for the
Super Chat I just want to say thanks for
everything you do the pitch accent
lessons as well as the content pointing
out the wonderful idiosyncras
idiosyncrasies of gen of everyday life
in Japan brings back memories of living
in Japan a couple of decades ago well
thank you very much and uh I really
appreciate the Super Chat and again I
love the movie
um and I'm glad that you enjoy both the
educational content as well as the
comedic content that means a lot to me
I think it was either a novel or a manga
before it became a movie
and I think it's based on a real story
but anyway
I like the movie
okay
when it comes to luxento like
does it concerns only a certain pair of
words or of all the words having the
same pronunciation
um it's a little bit difficult I can't
understand exactly what you're saying
the the English
but if you're
I think that the question is
how do I know if a word belongs to it
has an accent or doesn't have an accent
I apologize if I'm sorry yeah I'm not
making my coffee give me a second
okay here we go
okay I apologize for that guys smash the
legs
foreign
I got my coffee we're good to go uh
where was I
I can't remember what I was saying oh
afro in Japan how's it going dude it was
so great meeting you at the uh the
Halloween party
I should use this chance to make a
coffee too
I really want to meet um
Luke sometime as well Luke and Sophie
I mean in
for example there's a thing called muak
Center like for example they're they'll
not differ in Pitch of
[Music]
like we can see it done in other
dialects sorry for my poor explanation
um
oh okay I see what you're saying you're
saying
I believe that you're sane but aren't
there dialects in Japanese that don't
have any accent at all what's the point
of studying Japanese pitch accent if
there are some kinds of Japanese
dialects that don't have any accent at
all and or if
pitch accent in Osaka is different than
it is in Tokyo and this is a very common
question a lot of people say you don't
need to study pitch accent because pitch
accent is different in different areas
of Japan and
um it is true that pitch accent is
different depending on the area of Japan
that you're in but it's also true that
when Japanese speakers speak they nine
times out of 10 99 times out of ten they
speak with one unified pitch accent
system so people from Osaka speak in
Osaka Ben
and they don't switch into
the middle of a sentence or into Tokyo
Ben in the middle of a sentence and
people from Tokyo speak like they're
from Tokyo people from Oslo speak like
they're from Osaka people from Google
speak from their like they're from it
doesn't go like all over the place right
and it's the same thing in in English
I'm from Seattle so I speak like someone
that's from Seattle I don't suddenly
stop talking like this in the middle of
a sentence because I'm not from the UK
right so if you if you use the excuse of
I don't need to study Japanese pitch
accent because pitch accent is different
depending on the region
then you're going to get a bunch of
words wrong because you're going to be
studying standard Japanese in the
classroom
but you're going to be if you don't
study Japanese pitch accent then you'll
get the pitch accent of a bunch of words
wrong and when you say them with the
wrong pitch accent it'll be wrong for
standard Japanese
UK Dogan isn't real he can't hurt you
um
you might be saying them with the with
the right pitch accent for like you know
Osaka uh Osaka the Osaka dialect of
Japanese but again the thing is you're
not from Osaka so it won't sound like
you're speaking like a in a natural way
it's true that Japanese pitch accent is
different depending on the region but
you're not from that region so if you
don't study pitch accent and you care
about sounding natural it's fine if you
don't again I
pitch accent studies is really only
necessary for people like me and other
people that want to sound as natural as
possible but it's a fallacy it's not
true that um
because pitch accent is different
depending on the region you don't need
to study patriarchism if you care about
Pitch accent
yours you're learning Japanese standard
Japanese
almost guaranteed so if half of your
Japanese doesn't sound like standard
Japanese it will make your Japanese
sound fragmented and thus not natural
hopefully that makes sense
okay would you say uh G and G and Z is z
I was angry because my app did didn't
accept G in place of G and a
pronunciation quiz was it right to not
accept it okay oh this is a great
question
um
the answer is that they are pronounced
the same
and um I actually have a lesson I have a
lesson about all this stuff
hey go check out the series they are
pronounced identical they are pronounced
identical and the reason that they are
despite having different spellings is
because they used to not be pronounced
identically and slowly over time they
started to kind of mix a little bit and
then they would overlap and then in
Japanese like documents and stuff like
that at the time people would mix up the
two and then they mixed even more and so
now they are pronounced the same but in
the same way that in English there are
multiple sounds that sound like
like you can you can make an F you can
use an F to make a sound or you can use
a pH to make an
to make a
sound right there are two different ways
to make the same sound but only one of
those is is the correct spelling
depending on the word that you're
talking about so your question was
um would you say that G and G and z are
the same they are the same in the in the
terms of in how they're pronounced but
It's Your Dictionary uh was correct
if it's a pronunciation quiz then your
pronunciation was correct but your
spelling was incorrect so you didn't
make us you did not make a pronunciation
error but you did make a spelling error
if that makes sense and I I spend about
four or five minutes in that particular
lesson going into the history
of those two sounds and how they came
together and how uh there are only some
instances in Japanese where where those
sounds occur these days okay uh
okay let's see uh anything else
sorry I should have worn the the Dogan
merch today shouldn't I
um let's see maybe I can
uh merch
[Music]
I can't get the link right now that's
fine
um I'm here for the cringe where is it
my boy
is
all pronounced the same or is there a
tiny difference this is a really good
question and the answer is that it
depends
on the word and what I mean by that is
the three sounds that you just put up
those will basically always be
pronounced the exact same way okay but
if
that does not mean that
is always pronounced as o because it's
not and what I mean by that is if you
have a word like you know
then the first part of that word
it's pronounced not as tolu but as
[Music]
becomes an extension of the O right so
it's pull again not tall
however
if we take the word
um
to sorry let me try and
trying to find a good example of this I
guess the best example would be um
to to uh chase after someone
you s this is spelled in Japanese as oh
to chase in Japanese is spelled but it's
not pronounced
or it's pronounced so it depends on the
kind of word
in nouns generally speaking the
will will be said as as just one long or
but depending on
the kind of a word like if it's in a
verb again like as in then it's going to
not be o so it depends on the type of
word and again yeah yeah people are
typing in examples to this right now
this is another thing that I talk about
in my series I say you probably learned
this in in the classroom that e is
always e and that is always but it's not
here are the instances in which it's not
this and here are the instances in which
it is this
so I I break this down again in my
Series in detail
uh
uh wait really I thought it was all well
yeah again in like Tokyo tol Kyo it is
it is tall but not in to follow it's not
all it's oh
it is necessary to differentiate if you
want to sound natural because that's
what natives do they do different
differentiate okay uh do you know if uh
has any specific accent attributes
um I know that it has unique words that
they use like I know that they say all
the time
um but uh I don't know about like you
know the pitch accent of coke on that
kind of thing so I apologize for that
could you explain how to pronounce
so this is a great question so the two
in these sounds are pronounced
differently the one at the end of the
word is pronounced like an like a like a
deep throat and so to speak so your
tongue touches the very back of your
mouth but then the N the in the middle
is
articulated at the at the front of the
mouth so again it's
[Music]
like that this is how your tongue moves
in that sound
[Music]
okay so hopefully that answers your
question
okay
yeah so someone's typing out right now
like
eh uh
is a always pronounced as e no it's not
it is
in if you look at like
uh most words that have a then most of
the time it will be but there are
instances like specific cases and I made
a comedic video about this actually
when it's not pronounced as a when it's
not pronounced as e but it's pronounced
as
a and like maybe maybe a good example of
this would be like the word for like the
Japanese word for uh nice for example
is um
sorry uh
[Music]
yeah it's May it's not me it's
me
again not meh
May May
so there are certain nouns where it is
necessary to differentiate
and it's also true for like the word uh
flounder I believe
there's a certain kind of fish as well
um but then I it's also true for
um for certain for certain verbs so like
if you say to accept in Japanese that's
right here it goes from
right so is it
is
no it is not it's
all right so it's necessary to
differentiate between
e and e depending on the circumstances
again if you want to sound as natural as
possible
it's a misconception that a is always e
and that o is always o that's that's not
true
okay
okay uh studying pitch action early
means needing to unlearn fewer
mispronunciations yeah I guess there was
probably a question about how early
should I start paychecks and studies
um what I would recommend is my view on
this topic has kind of evolved over time
my current view is that I've got a few
lessons on YouTube that you can check
out
for free I think like I don't know the
first like four or five lessons
even if you're just starting to study
Japanese watch those lessons
because it'll it'll help it'll save you
from making some mistakes especially if
even if you've never studied Japanese
before you've been watching like a lot
of anime for a long time
um watch those lessons and then after
maybe like six lessons or so of pretty
good study then sign up for the patreon
because you want to study pitch accent
and pronunciation as early as possible
because it's it's so much easier to
develop a good habit than it is to
correct a bad habit and that means that
if you study pitch accent early on
you won't develop a ton of bad habits I
have a bunch of things wrong with my
spoken Japanese
because I didn't study them early enough
and like a good example of this is the r
sounds my teacher in a few textbooks
they really really
um
they taught the sound in a way that was
quite
um
misleading again it's like the Japanese
R sound or like it's like this flap
thing
yeah it's like this flap thing like
you're gonna do like this yeah don't
worry about it I was like I took their I
took that for granted and I've been
struggling to fix it ever since because
my mind made up my mind believed it and
again once you've once you've uh
developed those neural Connections in
your in your brain it's really hard to
to break those it's harder to again to
break a bad habit than it is to
establish a good one so I recommend
studying pitch accent and pronunciation
sooner than later if you've already been
studying Japanese for six months
I would say jump in right now again if
you care about your pronunciation in
Pitch accent okay what's the difference
between the Japanese or the Japanese D
the English d as far as how it's
supposed to sound okay I'm going to
break this down really really quickly
try um hopefully I can I can do this
okay so the Japanese
R sound is an alveolar tap it's
articulated at the alveolar Ridge right
behind the back of the Upper Front Teeth
the Japanese D sound
is is a denti alveolar stop so the tip
of your tongue is touching the back of
your upper front teeth and your alveolar
Ridge so already the tongue placement is
different than the Japanese R but it's
also articulated differently the
Japanese T and D again it's a stop it's
not a tap it's a stop
so it's pronounced slower
and the English D is
articulated in the same place as the
Japanese are but in English D is
articulated slower if you're talking
about a standard English d
so like if you say you know um
oh sorry there's I'm going to try and uh
get to this super chat in a second thank
you very much Weber for the Super Chat
Standard English D is also an alveolar
sound the tip of the tongue is touching
the alveolar Ridge just like the
Japanese R sound but the Japanese R
sound is an alveolar tap where the
English uh D and T sound is an alveolar
stop
okay so it's it's slower than than the
Japanese are now there are some
instances in which it's articulated as
an alveolar tap as in like you know
again butter and better and in in cases
like that it is pronounced identically
to the Japanese
um R so hopefully that answers your
question thank you for the education and
jokes as the patreon include the
comparisons between English and Japanese
sounds like earlier in the Stream hope
to use as alt
um let's see yeah I believe that in most
cases I do provide both an English and
Japanese recording and this is something
that I do for
um for pitch accent as well like it can
be very difficult if you're a native
English speaker to hear the difference
between
foreign
and so one of the things that I do is I
say okay let's take these two different
hitchhikes and patterns but say them
with English words
okay yeah and the the pronunciation sub
series does cover the differences quite
well okay so yes uh we do cover this in
detail in the pronunciation uh or yeah
in the pronunciation sub series which is
part of the series
okay um so sorry I'm having my um my
business partner JP helping helping me
with some of the comments as I'm going
through these he's kind of checking
patreon and stuff like that as I'm going
on over here okay uh can attest to the
patreon being very very good thank you
very much the Stellar Jang
um I am studying abroad in Osaka next
semester for six months what uh tips do
you have for improving my Japanese in
that time currently N2 level
um it really depends on what aspect of
your Japanese specifically you're
looking to improve I would ask yourself
what exactly about my Japanese do I want
to improve is it my kanji is it my
speaking is it my writing is it my
reading what is it
and because you're going to be studying
abroad I would say you can you can
practice reading and writing anywhere in
the world but if you're going to be in
Japan
it's probably best to try and do as much
speaking as much conversation as
possible because once you leave Japan
it's harder to of course speak with
native speakers
so hopefully that answers your question
okay been looking into subbing the
patreon series in your opinion on a high
level what's the ratio of pitch action
rules being applied arbitrarily versus
regular enough that there's a system to
it
um well it's hard to say
because there are so many different
factors that play into it but I I
whenever I introduce a rule I try and
talk about how important that specific
rule is so earlier on I talk about like
the four the four Mora two konzi uh noun
Rule and I say remember this right now
this is extremely important
because it is but then like later on in
the series during the very very high
Advanced pitch accent sub series
uh Advanced pitch accent sub series when
we talk about like numbers there's a ton
of exceptions to numbers and so
I say here's the rule but the very first
thing that I say before all those
lessons on numbers is I say
there are a bunch of rules for numbers
in Japanese but there's a lot of
exceptions so I'm going to present you
guys with this information because
there's a lot of really high level
people that want to know this
but it's just as important to know that
half of the time native speakers don't
play by these particular rules
so again I always basically try and say
here are the rules
here are the really important ones here
are the pretty important ones and here
are the not so important ones then you
can determine exactly which rules you
would like to remember and try and apply
based on your particular goals that's
how I try and do it okay I often be I
often hear who being pronounced as a
Velar fricative Velar fricative sound or
something similar what context does this
happen Velar fricative well it's should
be a bilabial fricative
for
uh
feeler fricative sorry I'm I'm unable to
answer that right now
um that's a little bit
that's either something that I
intentionally decided to leave out of
the series because I determined that
that would not be practical for most
people or something that I didn't come
across in my research so I apologize for
that okay
um okay love you Duggan you keep you've
kept me motivated to study parkour Chris
hey cool incidentally I never did
parkour but I used to do tricking
martial arts tricking I used to be
really really really into it
so does speaking Japanese with the
correct accents is it really that
important or does Japanese people do not
care as long as you're understood
um the answer to this is that it depends
on the person
um
it depends on the person that you're
speaking to
and what I mean by this is that
most people don't care
if you have a if you have a perfect
accent or a pretty good accent or not
most people they will say that they
don't care and and nine times out of ten
they won't treat you any differently
but there are many instances in which if
you do have a an accent that sounds much
more natural much more native
people will immediately assume
that
they can speak to you
um that they will understand anything
that they say to you but that you will
understand anything that they say to you
so even if you can speak Japanese more
fluently than me in the sense of you
never have to like I stutter all the
time when I'm speaking both English and
Japanese
um like I'm constantly saying to myself
like
um
so like I'm always like searching for
the next thing to say I'm like doing
like brain farts that's just because I'm
not a very eloquent speaker right
and so
um that's kind of like you know just
kind of a problem that I have
so there are many people that never
stutter like that when they speak
Japanese
um but they have pretty bad uh accents
so like they'll say like pretty basic
Japanese words like for example they'll
say the word for Japanese language as
not
they'll say nihongo like people will say
like
it's like I didn't stutter at all when I
was saying that right but if a native
speaker hears you say that I made three
pretty bad pitch accident mistakes in
that sentence okay so if a native
speaker hears you say that
they'll they'll still probably be
equally nice to you even if your accent
isn't that good they probably won't be
like oh this person's like an idiot I I
don't want to waste my time with them No
One's Gonna you know
treat you like like a like a lesser
person because you have an accent but
people will assume that you can
understand more Japanese the more
natural your Japanese is
and you know it's kind of like the same
thing you can probably think about
similar instances in your own native
language right like I'm a native English
speaker so if I hear someone speaking
English
um perfect English and they have
absolutely no accent then I'll assume
that I can speak to them like I would
speak to any other native speaker
because they're probably a native
speaker right but if I speak to a
Japanese person
that is very eloquent but during the
first couple minutes that I talked to
them they're uh or maybe like you know
the first 30 seconds or whatever it
might be if they're they're making if
they have a very very thick accent then
I might unconsciously assume that oh
they might not understand everything
that I'm saying I'm going to treat them
equally nice I'm going to treat them
with the same respect and dignity that I
should treat everyone but I might choose
different words when I speak to them I
think that's you know just kind of like
an
unconscious thing that people do it's
like you know you could you could do the
same thing for like uh sports or
whatever it's like you're going to see
make kind of like a hypothesis like okay
this is the level that this person is at
and because I I've seen them doing this
particular thing at this particular
level well then probably based on this
evidence they probably do these these
other things at this level
so again the thing that I really want to
stress here is that people won't treat
you with any less respect they won't
treat you with any less dignity because
you have a thick accent no nobody cares
but again they'll probably will assume
that
you are better at Japanese if your
Japanese sounds more natural
so I think I'm repeating myself at this
point but
um I think that that is the truth
um maybe a you know a controversial
thing to say and I also want to really
really really stress that if you don't
care about having a foreign accent
then then don't worry about studying
pitch accent and pronunciation like I
know tons of people that probably enjoy
their lives in Japan more than me and
they've they speak with bad pitch accent
and bad pronunciation
but they don't care about it and the
people that they're talking to don't
care about it and they just you know go
about their lives and they have
different goals and I have different
goals so it's fine you know what what
are your goals what do you want to sound
like what do you want people uh what do
you want your perception of people uh
what do you want others perception of
you to be you know it's all comes down
to the individual there's no correct
answer I always just try and provide the
information and say if you want to sound
as native as possible you probably
should study this
uh okay let's keep going I gotta go
oh I gotta go
now
a good question here Kaiser Franz uh do
I need to know much grammar to follow
your lessons on patreon
um I'm a 2B kanji master who fails to
study actual Japanese
um
I like to say that no you don't need to
know very much grammar at all and that's
because I teach Japanese generally
speaking at the word level
there's a couple lessons at the at the
um at the sentence level where I say
like this is what you should think this
is how you should think of pitch accent
and pronunciation
um when you're speaking in in sentences
and stuff like that but you get all the
benefit from studying pitch accent at
the word level so even if you don't know
the word that I'm saying
I still write the English you know
meaning of the word on screen I'll have
the con the kanji the Chinese characters
I'll have the hiragana
so that you can pronounce it even if you
don't know the Chinese characters and
then I'll also have you know again the
English meaning so you don't need to
know the words
um the meaning of the words in order to
benefit from the series
um again it if you have a little bit of
Japanese under your belt then that
that's good because you'll know many of
the words that I that I teach in my
series but it's okay if you don't know
the words that I teach because you can
learn them along the way so hopefully
that answers your question okay
um
for me it's just chasing that first
yeah yeah
uh if you can do basic conjugations
you're fine it's very intuitive yeah and
just like you know I talk about like how
you know the the dictionary form of a uh
of a verb the accent will be like this
but then like in in the past conjugation
it'll be like this and then in like you
know the nagada conjugation it'll be
like this etc etc so
um the pitch accent series is very very
thorough
um and again it kind of goes across
three levels I think that more or less
anyone that wants to sound natural
should definitely go through at least
the the basic series and and the
pronunciation series as well but there's
a lot of high level pitch accent stuff
that it's really I made those lessons
specifically because there was like a
very small group of people that were
like I want to know everything and so I
was like okay let me try and make some
lessons about this
okay so
um let's see the ones I didn't know at
the time was
okay okay guys well uh yep I gotta get
going I need to work out I haven't
worked out in a couple days and I gotta
pick up the kids fairly soon so I gotta
get going but I had a lot of fun doing
this oh Andy bad timing I'm like leaving
right now my friend Andy takini Andy he
teaches Japanese
um uh not so much pitch acts and stuff
like I do but he's a great Japanese
teacher really good Japanese I would
encourage everyone to check out his
channel as well I gotta get going but
thanks everyone for stopping in I had a
great time and if you guys found this
useful
um maybe let me know in a comment down
below and maybe we can potentially do
another thing like this in the future
where it's kind of like more impromptu
but there are some graphics and that
kind of thing okay I'm being redundant
at this point so I'm gonna get going
thank you guys very much for stopping in
if you're interested check out the
Japanese pitch accent series pitch
accent and pronunciation series on
patreon and I'll see you all again soon
all right talk to you guys later
bye bye